school buses are well joining us now is
Wayne Slater Wayne Slater is the Dallas
Morning News
Austin bureau chief he's also the
co-author of this book Bush's brain how
Karl Rove made George W Bush
presidential mr. Slater how long have
you been covering George Bush since his
father was the president States and he
was the young son so really I covered
his campaign intensely started in 1993
when he began the campaign for governor
of Texas his administration jumped on
the airplane in June of 1999 and when he
decided to run for president and cut off
in November of 2000 so it's been a long
time it's so far during this convention
have you seen the hand of Karl Rove in
what's been going on I have I mean Carl
is I've known I've covered Carl and been
around Carl longer I think that George
Bush Carl was an important figure I
think in in Texas in the early 1980s in
the mid 1980s serving other politicians
so he's extraordinary he's brilliant
he's a great tactician and strategist
he's really good he understands that you
focus and he's a great compliment to
Bush I've seen Rove throughout this this
this credential so far it has there been
a speech that's from the convention
floor that hasn't been approved by Karl
Rove oh no every speech has been a read
by you know Matthew Dowd Ken Mehlman and
others on the only on the campaign but I
talked to Carl and Carl said yes no he
had an opportunity to see every
certainly every major speech and I
suspect knowing Carl that he's looked
over everything that said on that stage
this is a very disciplined party his MO
is to really focus on detail and so it
stands to reason and you know Carl says
this is nothing new
they the campaigns have done this on
both sides for twenty thirty years where
you've had some kind of discipline and
focus and attention to the tale this is
the expression of the party this is the
expression obviously of the candidate in
this case the President of the United
States what he wants to say and what he
wants the party to say for the
re-election so it stands to reason that
his number one political guru would
would make sure that all the
says all the singers are singing from
the same hymn book what did you here
last night with Zell Miller and Dick
Cheney well you know again you'd be able
to see sort of the Turner
it's a remarkable I think convention so
far the first couple of nights had some
elements of compassionate conservatism
and some attack what you began to see
last night was a more direct look really
I think the most direct look we're going
to see at comparing John Kerry to George
Bush it's the traditional role of the
vice president to do that and that's
what he did last night it was a fairly
sharp attack but Cheney has this
extraordinary ability to present a
critique in a an almost monotone way
very sharp very definite very clear
defining the difference between John
Kerry and George Bush raising questions
about whether he is stable with with a
waffle or you know flip-flopper and so
forth Zell Miller here we've got a
Democrat very conservative Democrat from
the south whose values were really much
more in line with many in the Republican
Party on the conservative wing of the
party he was passionate some say he
looked a little angry last night it was
a sharp pratik of John Kerry and very
quickly what do you think President Bush
is going to say tonight well you know he
really has two goals and the first goal
is to to make sure that is reinforcing
the idea that he is strong and stable
the commander in chief that's the goal
we understand of course he's going to
talk about looking to the future I
remember you know he's look back at his
father in 1992 and whether or not that
administration the incumbent did enough
and talking about the future against
Bill Clinton when George Bush ran
against Ann Richards in 1994 for
governor and one one of the critiques of
Ann Richards was that she did not talk
about what she would do in the future
it's a lesson he's learned well we're
gonna see it tonight our guest is Wayne
Slater he's the co-author of this book
Bush's brain how Karl Rove made George W
Bush presidential in reading your book I
was a little bit surprised when you said
that you recently talked to Karl
he was he's he's a professional this guy
he knows what he's doing but this was a
gathering here at a for young college
republicans I self Karl got his start as
a member of young college Republicans
but Lee Atwater and he was there and I
was sitting by the bar area drinking a
coke and he say hey the next rounds on
me or maybe the next round ought to be
on you but no he was friendly and
courteous it's a sharp critical look at
the relationship between bush and Rove
the book is but look he's got an office
in the White House and I think he's
secure and who he is
you refer to him as a co-president yeah
you know a lot of people think that this
is we're saying something bad about
George Bush George Bush is a bright guy
and I've said this for years there is
this this idea that George Bush is dumb
and that this book a book that has
titled Bush's brain means that the
president doesn't have a brain that's
not what we're saying at all
what we're saying is that this
relationship between Karl Rove and
George Bush is a perfect compliment Bush
is a sort of a easygoing interesting
gregarious open person with an
extraordinary emotional IQ and dealing
with people Rove always has been this
brainy strategic minded extraordinarily
brilliant political strategist together
and provides this sort of intellect and
strategy in a campaign together they're
a pretty formidable team first call for
Wayne Slater is on our support Senator
Kerry Line New Orleans you're on the air
yes I'm listening that this man with all
of this kooky talk that he's talking
about when you tell a lie it's a lie if
you tell that lie hundred times it's
civilized country into war and and I
mean it's like everything they report is
fluff why don't you report something
that's all substantial no jobs
thank you call Wayne Slater well
the great thing about it I think this
this campaign is is the extraordinary
passion I think some people bring to it
we've seen a nation this year the s is
as divided passionately divided with
people who are unhappy with George Bush
and people who really love George Bush
in the administration and I think that's
a reflection of that
you know I saw Ken Mehlman of the the
campaign manager and Matthew Dowd that
the president's strategist a couple of
days ago and they're really talking
about a fairly small group of undecideds
or persuadable voters especially
undecided voters out there because a lot
of people have made up their mind they
either like George Bush or they don't
were you aware that Tommy Franks is
gonna be speaking tonight yeah that I
Tommy Frank did you learn that last
night I heard it this morning actually I
did not know that last night I suspect
this had been in the works for a while I
suspect there are surprises afoot I
don't know you think there'll be any
other surprises don't know what do you
think about this stage that they are
constructing in Madison Square Garden
we'll take a look at it they're making
it a theater in the round here for
President Bush well we have heard that
something was going to happen something
like that and I was out on the floor
over the weekend and looked and I was
quite envision what it was obviously
they want to make this dramatic but I
think I think the idea is to sort of it
rejects some sense of intimacy that he's
there on the floor with the people
around him so it'll be interesting to
see what it looks like
Dalton Georgia good morning you're on
with Wayne Slater hello my name is Jane
maples I'm a 57 year old baby boomer
from Dawson Georgia I'm proud of Zell
Miller I'm proud that I can say I'm from
Georgia I've traveled to the Middle East
and have personal knowledge of the
situation in the Middle East my father
was a prisoner of war in Germany and he
has paid the price for freedom and our
family is much aware of the cost of
freedom and I'm very very disappointed
and all of the Americans have found it
more important to complain about their
plight instead of support all the people
who trying see the
peace in the world they can call her
wince later back to the war well it is
and you know that really is the dominant
theme of this this campaign it's
interesting Karl Rove back in 1919 2002
spoke to a group of Republican sort of
heavyweights and the party at a party
National Party gathering in Austin Texas
obviously after 9/11 and he said at this
point we had we had gone to Afghanistan
he said this is an issue the war on
terror this war is something we can run
on in 2004 and 2002 of the midterm
elections this is an issue that we can
take to the nation and he's right his
strategy whatever we talk about whatever
whatever is talked about tonight about
the economy the president's gonna talk
about the ownership society issues of
well and I'm not sure what that means
except its health care and maybe some
taxes and some other things whatever he
talks about let me tell you this is
about the war our handling of the war
and and the Bush administration wants to
press the idea that this is the
president to stay with he'll protect you
at home and the carry administer the
Kerry campaign obviously is pressing the
idea that we are in bad shape we're at a
place we shouldn't have been and the war
is a dominant issue in a negative way is
the economy in bad shape well you know
you know what's the old joke about
economist you can ask well ask many and
get that many different opinions clearly
the economy is not in great shape this
is not where this administration wants
to be in an odd way despite the fact
that the war has not gone well in Iraq
in many ways it there is a sort of
tainted silver lining here for George
Bush and that is that if in fact there
were no war or if in fact the war had
turned out alright and we were focused
back on the economy which is at best
fairly mediocre performing in a mediocre
way then I think that might not accrue
to the president's favor as it is I
think the the Bush administration based
on the people I talked to in the Bush
campaign think that they can take this
issue of security at home and the
stability of the commander-in-chief
and can win re-election focus largely on
that now that President Bush is a
national figure have you lost your
access being a Texas figure yeah pretty
much tell me I have to be honest with
you uh one day I was at the White House
and and of a pretty good relationship
with the president I mean as a
professional relationship as a reporter
known him for so many years and in the
old days we used to go over the
Statehouse in Austin and go up in his
office and just kick back and talk and
he was open and accessible because
that's the way governors are the
relationship I think is probably a good
one I haven't really talked to him and
over here well almost a year now I see
him from a distance and say hello in
Washington but I'm based back in Texas
at one point I was in the the White
House a little over a year ago and saw
him and the president said no what's
this you've written a book and you say
Karl Rove is my mentor and I said no sir
mr. president all I've said is he's
smarter than you are now
people around him kind of thought that
was a problem but I but he laughed and
he knew that I meant that in good fun
next call for Wayne Slater Boyton beach
florida you're on the air uh yes good
morning and thank you for c-span I I'm
gonna speak about the war something I
noticed during the convention
I know Karl Rove is brilliant I don't
particularly care for him as a human
being I I understand he's playing
towards his base but as a moderate I'm a
moderate Democrat but do you think that
the overemphasis of religion is going to
scare off the other moderates the
moderate Republicans and also world
leaders because you know you talk about
the ideological war between communism
versus democracy which is fine now we're
fighting terrorism or extreme Islamic
fundamentalism and whereas Kerry says I
don't wear my religion on my sleeve
Bush's out there you've got Giuliani
saying you know thank God you know Bush
was our president and and Zell Miller
and and practically anointing him and
you know that's really scary because
then that turns the war
into you know the Christians versus the
Islamic religion as opposed to the
democratic values of the United States
versus extreme Islamic terrorists and I
just wondered where you thought if you
thought karl rove was looking at that
bigger picture or has just lasered in on
getting Bush re-elected by jazzing up
the base that's a great question it's a
big question I can't answer all of it
but I do know that yes he is looking at
that if this is a fine line that the
Bush campaign has to has to walk and
Rove understands this and certainly
Ralph Reed the former chairman of the
Christian Coalition who is the Bush
campaigns southeast coordinator
understands this I've been to Atlanta
and talked to Ralph about this that the
goal is to do exactly that based on my
conversations with people inside the
Bush administration in the Kerry
Administrator Kerry campaign it appears
that there really will be a focus as you
say on Jenning up the base on working on
the base and most maybe the most
reliable segment of that base tour
Christian evangelicals and other social
conservatives who support the President
and you're right this has the potential
of being an off-putting thing for people
who are moderates persuadable voters
moderate Republicans people are
undecided so what you're going to see or
maybe a better way to say it is what
you're not going to see I think is a
broader message that talks a little bit
about the faith and values nationally
but if you were to go to these places
like Southeast Ohio important state but
a socially conservative region or a
Georgia which is a red state that still
has many socially conservative voters
what you're going to see between now and
November is what's called narrow casting
you're going to see church groups prayer
sessions Christian radio and other
smaller more focused and direct ways to
communicate to this base in ways that
the bush campaign hopes doesn't alienate
and won't alienate other more moderate
voters it's a sophisticated way of
campaigning but that's the way that's
where they are
or WIC New York good morning hi I have a
few observations on the Republican
convention I the gentleman might want to
comment on one I don't see any deleted
the people running in the government
where's Ashcroft and Rumsfeld the
Condoleezza Rice and Colin Powell we and
another observation
there's Cheney there 24/7 all week long
while George Bush the president is out
on the campaign trail but George Bush
has promptly made over a hundred
campaign appearances since the 9/11 and
fundraisers I don't know any Commander
in Chief's that have ever served that
way while Cheney mans the fort and then
all let's get a response when slated
well I mean I think it's traditional
that the first the the the the president
when you have a president or even the
candidate if it's in either case comes
to the campaign convention on the final
day comes late and makes a big
appearance sure the president has done
campaigning the president has worked in
the White House that you know this is an
assessment that voters have to make they
have to think as the president spent
more time than I'm comfortable with on
the campaign trail it's a decision that
people have to make Chicago good morning
you're on the air good morning I just
want to say thank God we have a
president Bush there now I feel so much
safer I did not even care well thank you
mr. Kerry senator Kerry for your service
but I don't thank you for your
disservice coming back when those poor
men were in the handle I helped me
suffering because of you he just changes
his mind every few minutes I just want
to let you know all those people out
there President did a President Bush did
win that election and when Kennedy was
running here in Chicago guess what Mayor
Daley burned the ballots there was no
recount so we have a president who is
duly elected by the people and has our
interests in hand and thank you God
bless you President Bush and he's going
to be our president again for four more
years thanks Colin well it's you know
again a manifestation of this support
out there from folks on both sides
I'm gonna tell you I live in Texas and
folks there by and large like the
president I travel in the campaign
different places to the blue states and
to sort of the purple states I guess
somewhere in between and there's a lot
of passion out there people some people
liking some people really don't they I
think the thing that struck me was
covering George Bush as governor I saw a
guy who focused because in large part
the legislature was democratic who
focused on working in a bipartisan way
and really developed this reputation of
being friendly and open and winning
people over and being the very opposite
of a divisive figure and so now to see
him in this at this moment in our
history is is really a place I never
thought I'd date now that Karen Hughes
is back on the campaign
what's her role well she's you know
she's critical I saw so many times in
ninth in 2000 where the were that were
the ship the campaign would be listing
in one direction or another and she'd be
there to to pull it back she's a master
of image the the sights behind the
candidate the the essence of the message
is he on she's very instinctive in terms
of understanding what's out there what
are people feeling where should the
president be where should he not be most
important thing about Kara news is he
trusts her he absolutely trust Kara news
to to she's the person who could say no
you're absolutely wrong mr. president
and I think that maybe he/she Karl Rove
and his wife and that maybe about it
what's her relationship with Karl Rove
the relationship is a is a professional
one good and as you would expect these
are two powerful people very powerful
work together
Karen use was the executive director of
the Republican Party in in Texas back in
and I guess 1990 and Karl Rove was a
young political operative who at that
point was trying to pick up George Bush
as a potential gubernatorial candidate
he didn't run until four years later so
they've been in Republican politics
together in Texas for a long time they
really serve different purposes
the in the office when George Bush was
elected Karl Karl was outside after the
election of George Bush in 1994 he had a
private business a consulting business
political consulting business a
gradually Bush became his only client
Karen use was always inside she was
always his political advisor and
confidant and in terms of media strategy
or image political consultants she was
she was there they really complement
each other because Karl's harder and
more strategic Karen has kind of a
bigger picture of things in the sense of
how how is this message going over and
and I think they work well together John
McCain has been spending a lot of time
on the campaign trail with George Bush
what's the backstory they're from Texas
oh man let me tell you that's that's a
beautiful I remember at one point in
South Carolina in 2000 this is when the
attacks by the bush allies on John
McCain were at their highest and McCain
was upset and publicly talked about and
blame George Bush for these what he felt
were vicious attacks on himself and his
family they were in a studio before the
debate in South Carolina in 2000 and
your Jedi McCain John McCain you know
John it's only politics and one to shake
his hand and McCain said you know George
not everything is politics McCain still
to this day based on people we know we I
think we both know inside the McCain
operation still is unhappy with George
Bush and George Bush's campaign from
that 2000 race he felt he was unfairly
attacked he felt that his family was
unfairly maligned but he is a I guess
good soldier and a certainly a loyal
Republican and so when you see him out
there you wonder is this a guy who not
only is supporting the president because
he supports the party and I think
there's part of that or is this a guy
that despite his denials still sees the
potential of the White House in four
years from now don't know who was to mr.
McCain's consultant his Karl Rove well
his real karl rove was a guy named john
Wever there's another guy like Murphy
who is a political consultant they sort
of maybe they since Karl Rove is the
most extraordinary genius in the history
of the 20th century in terms of and some
people think the darkest force in the in
the 20th century of 20 early 21st
century it takes two people I think the
equal Karl so I think Weaver John Weaver
who was once an ally friend and an
associate of Rove in Texas they had a
parting of the ways
what you saw in 2000 and in a weird way
you see now are these two people karl
rove the advisor and sort of political
genius behind the president on one side
and then you see John Weaver and advisor
extraordinary political advisor behind
McCain they do not like each other so
you have this backstory of two advisors
who have there's no friendship lost
their advising two men whose
relationship remains prickly even as
they campaign together next call for
Wayne Slater is belén New Mexico you're
on the air go ahead hello my name is
Phil Martinez and um I'd like to refer
people to the book fortunate son by
James Hatfield and in my reading here
it was Karl Rove who spoke to Hatfield
about the cocaine use that that Bush was
involved with and the last weekend's
that nobody ever talks about the times
that he went to Mexico and he doesn't
even have a recollection of the time he
spent there he was probably so drugged
up and and drunk and and also the the
fact that George Bush doesn't even
possess his original driver's license
because of the of what his dad was able
to accomplish with the with the judge
helping him to purge his records and
this book here was the pulped it was it
was the Bush family tried to keep this
bulk book from coming out in print and
it was picked up by the soft skull press
and it was Karl Rove who told James
Hatfield about the cocaine use Thank You
caller Wayne Slater well that's a book
that
has a lot of a lot of charges in it I
refer you to Bush his brain my book
which has some elements I have to say
that these allegations about the
president's so-called drug use or
something that certainly as a reporter
I've looked into and other reporters
have I've never seen any evidence that
of any illegal drug use by the president
he does admit that he was he did drink
drank too much and stopped drinking some
years ago Newberry South Carolina good
morning Newberry South Carolina okay
we're gonna move on we're going to move
on to Salem Ohio Salem Ohio you're on
the air yes go ahead Ohio you are ready
an article in The New York Times whereby
they were talking about crown lawyers
and that was about two months ago you
read that article I'm wondering if you
remember that I remember reading
articles about trial lawyers but what's
your point caller the article actually
concluded the trial lawyers were nothing
but thugs one of the things I don't
understand is that Edwards who carry
picked is a trial lawyer and his
specialty was suing doctors and I read
in Time magazine where he got one award
where he got six and a half million
dollars in one case and it was later
reduced to Fornaio million um but he
sued because a baby didn't turn out
correctly and eventually what they found
out was the baby in three broke palsy
and that's a prenatal condition and had
nothing to do with the delivery but
anyway one of my questions
we how can we have a guy like that that
the times would say would probably be a
thug as a vice president
I think Thank You caller Wayne Slater by
lawyers important major important part
of funding Democratic Party candidates
Fred Baron a lawyer in Dallas is a trial
lawyer represents injured people against
companies and asbestos cases by and
large and is a key figure in the carry
Edwards campaign this is a big debate in
some quarters and I'm always amazed when
I go out and I hear Republicans in
crowds talk about things like
education and you certainly understand
how people are interested in that and
talk about war and peace and inevitably
people are very sophisticated about the
tort issue about try lawyers and and and
their and a lawsuit lawsuits against
businesses and doctors and others
President Bush and other Republicans
will say and I'm going to work on tort
reform and inevitably get a great
response from Republican crowds so
people understand I think this issue if
the trial lawyers are the fundamental
funding source I think on the Democratic
side many business interests are on the
other side but let me remind the caller
of one thing I was a great story not
long ago in the Wall Street Journal in
which the Republican part whether trial
lawyers basically or now backing some
moderate Republican candidates so
they're not exclusively supporting
Democrats they're supporting some
Republicans and in the campaign and like
you said Fred Barron is one of John
Edwards top contributors have you talked
to Fred Barron and Ella a lot and in
fact I saw him in in in Boston I saw him
in a giant soiree when I wasn't just
small soiree ben barnes who is was the
former lieutenant governor and a big
fundraiser for folks democrats in the
senate had a soiree at some venetian
mansion it was a fundraiser and so I got
in invitation and beautiful pictures
Botticelli's on the wall and sergeants
and these great pieces of Arts and
it looked like about half the Senate
Democrats or there Patrick Leahy and
others walking around with wine and coke
and water and and at one point Ben
Barnes put his arms around John Corzine
senator Carson and said you know there's
not anybody in this room as a fundraiser
not anybody in this room who can't spare
twenty five thousand dollars and you
know I looked across the room and
there's Fred Barron and there's a number
of other trial lawyers I know and other
business leaders who support Democrats
and I listened to that there's nobody in
this room who can't support twenty five
thousand dollars and I looked and I
looked and I thought I guess I'm about
the only one who can next call Broken
Arrow Oklahoma you're on the air for you
to put on your reporter hat and go for
this the Joseph William the Joseph
William Wilson story it has been counted
that Karl Rove was maybe behind Bob
Novak and personally I have written
letters to CNN to get him off the air I
think he is the lowest of the low when
it comes to a quarter seventeen
appointed this CIA wise he outed her
Frank for no reason there was no story
there to leak her name and when the
Republicans talk about intelligence
reform and and how our intelligence
community needs to be funded better and
and really gets on John Kerry for not
quote-unquote funding intelligence with
his bills by signing a certain bill or
whatever what does it say when we would
just destroy someone's life and and
their career by outing their name for no
reason and that is one of our CIA
operatives and that came out of the
White House I think it will be found out
that that it will and then it did come
right out of the White House who she was
and they outed her for no other reason
other than Joseph William Wilson I'm
having trouble with that name but we got
we got the point thanks caller and in
your the paperback version of your book
you have a new update and you write that
people would be surprised if Karl Rove
or not behind the Valerie Plame
that's right you know let me be clear we
don't have on paper evidence yet I don't
think anybody does
exactly how this transpired exactly how
the leak came from the White House that
outed the identity of a CIA operative
Valerie Plame wife of Joe Wilson the
ambassador but but I think as we look at
the long evidence as we look at what
happened in this case and the sort of
history in which karl rove has been
involved what we see is an extraordinary
pattern we see a pattern of activity and
whether Carl was the first caller or
whether he fanned the flames otherwise
or whether he initiated the the effort
that subsequently someone else made the
call to Bob Novak I don't know justice
is looking into it Justice Department I
I assume we'll get to the bottom of it
but I think there is substantial
evidence in the way of a pattern that
this is exactly the kind of thing that
karl rove has done in the past
Associated Press is reporting that there
were two large explosions in the area of
the school in Russia where the children
are being held hostage we'll keep you
updated on that st. Charles Illinois
you're on with Wayne Slater of the
Dallas Morning News good morning good
morning
I am a quest portray for the last time
and I'll vote this time for him but my
point got tougher than that
well I was watching a c-span coverage of
the Republican convention I also was
watching the the protest the one he had
on for that and I was having a friend of
mine of an elderly Chinese woman and she
was very frightened about all the people
on the street were placed in retreat in
New York and I realized I had a hard
time explain to her what peaceful
protest was in the US and that reminds
me how right they were to be able to
have their peace and how much were all
Americans we were very hopeful thank you
thank you collard greens later well you
know I there were a lot of talk before
this
invention is this going to be a is this
going to be a reprise of Chicago 1968
where we had what some people believe
was a police riot or certainly was a
riot and whoever caused it whether hood
and boy it looks like to me here in the
streets of New York that the police are
acting in extraordinarily responsible
way and even though there has been
protest in some cases rowdy protests and
there have been arrests lots of arrests
I think people have been by and large
free to express their opinion I think
the police have responded I think
responsibly and man this city's handling
this awfully well
have you been harassed at all or shouted
at or any well a little bit I think it's
because I remember at one time I left
the hall at about 10 11 o'clock at night
was walking back because I love to walk
you want to walk if you can because the
city's just the city is not Round Rock
Texas this is a different place and and
I think it's because I had a suit on in
a briefcase which was my computer and so
yeah they were harassing me as part of
the rich elite Republican whatever and
if they only knew I'm just a stooge
reporter are you a fan of george w bush
I am a I am a reporter and I really
think that my coverage over the years
has been good and bad Karen used and on
occasion George Bush has let me know
when they don't like things I've written
on the other hand I've written things
that are that are good he is a person
and I and I say this as a person whose
book about the relationship between karl
rove is quite critical especially of
rove this relationship which in many
ways is dark and manipulative at the
same time i'm a person who has said to
people if you meet george bush as I have
over the years in a room one-on-one or
in small groups it seems to me almost
impossible not to like him he is a
wonderful person
very nice very friendly his policies are
something that people many people do not
like many other people like a lot I'm
trying to separate his policies and my
sort of fair and balanced reporting of
his policies from the man and my fan of
George Bush I'm a person certainly
respects him as president
and enjoy being around him as a
personality as a president I think I'll
leave that to the historians Knoxville
Tennessee you're on the air
yes I'd like to make a couple of
observations I called in on the Kari
line but I you know I'm really not for
Bush or for Kerry and I watched all the
of the Democratic convention so far I've
watched all the Republican convention
and you know what concerns me I'm on
disability
I draw 750 dollars a month and you just
can't pay your bills on that you know I
have went a day and a half with nothing
to eat because I have to choose between
paying rent and my utilities and eating
color can I ask a question then can I
can i play devil's advocate for a minute
how is it that you're able to have cable
and make long-distance phone calls then
well you know I'll have to suffer for
that when when the bill comes due okay I
have to hear how that's going to be how
you going to help people like me and
there's people in a lot worse shape than
me and what I don't understand whether
it's Bill Clinton or John Kerry or
George Bush is how we can drop bombs on
Sodom Hussein and then drop a care
package so we're feeding people overseas
but what about the people in this
country what about the people that go
hungry ever not here people that have
children whose children go to bed
wanting something to eat
Thank You caller Wayne Slater well you
know I talked to tad Devine who was
yesterday who was John Kerry's
strategist political strategist and Ted
said you know we when you talk to them
or to focus on the issues of health care
and and and your family and people with
disabilities as this caller was talking
about in an interesting way and maybe an
unfortunate way for the Kerry campaign
the talk of war the issue of terrorism
has really and for obvious and probably
good reason obscured in large part this
domestic debate about health care
and about taxes and the redistribution
of taxes and about disabilities so I
think the Democrats would like to talk
more about exactly what this caller is
talking about and I think the bush
people will talk a little I think the
president will talk a little bit tonight
about his approach a Republican approach
to dealing with health care and other
matters but by and large this this
enormous cloud of terrorism and the war
seems to have obscured dominated much of
the debate last night in his speech I
think it was the first time I've ever
heard Dick Cheney talk about education
that's funny I've never thought about it
quite but you're right you're absolutely
right that that's that's not who he is
of course he's this insider ultimate
insider inside the White House this this
this notorious or extraordinarily
brilliant neocon and and confidant of
the president you know his forte is is
is his foreign policy is not education
and so you're right it is I think kind
of unusual to see him talk about that
Moundville Pennsylvania good morning
yeah go ahead
well yeah I just kind of have an
observation I wonder why the media why
they back away I don't see how a mention
of this terrorist act of come on over
and Russia they caught Chechen rebels
were basically Islamic terrorists and
you know we seem to be all worried if we
would destroy their religious temple and
I mean we got to think of our safety
mainly Americans the other thing is like
the previous call that was on it's a
true concern you know not having wonder
where the minds gonna come for things
like that when they're disabled or
whatever but sometimes there's a bigger
picture out thanks cooler winds later
yeah and I think that's what the Bush
campaign understands I think you know if
certainly we want to pay our health
bills certainly we want to have our
children have the best education these
are the values of America
these are what government ought to be a
part of but you know if you if you if
you're dead then though that's really
kind of irrelevant the fear or the war
on terrorism this whole issue is so
important to so many people it really
skews the debate so the caller's right I
think in Tom de frank writes in the New
York Daily News today that Bush flies
high but remembers 2000 nosedive near
death election experience when he was
way ahead but came close has prompted
Bush to place less reliance than some
polls on the spreadsheets and analytical
memos cited by his campaign experts and
to trust his gut yeah I remember one
time I think was February maybe early
late January 2000 sitting in a motel
with a snow outside in New Hampshire
with Karl Rove with this napkin where he
wrote you know there's this whole group
of numbers and sort of like a fever
chart of various polls and data and so
forth which he concluded meant that
George Bush was going to win New
Hampshire and George Bush did not win
New Hampshire and so I think the
president has learned along the way that
there's that there's more out there than
simply the statistical analysis when I
was in Boston a month ago I went over to
Cambridge and talked to George McGovern
who had been the nominee for president
in 1992 and it was it was interesting to
talk to this this person who is the
nominee in that race but one of the
things he said was when he ran he knew
it was gonna be tough he knew it was
gonna be difficult to beat Nixon but
their only chance their only opportunity
their only hope was that enough votes
would vote for George Wallace when
Wallace was shot McGovern
told me he knew it was over 10 million
votes moved to Richard Nixon and so here
you have the nominee in effect saying
events dictate the outcome of campaigns
sometimes events we cannot judge and
cannot predict and we cannot control
whether that event in this campaign
would be some kind of terrorist attack
whether it would be the outcome of the
debate whether it be an unusually
positive economic number events that
cannot be controlled in large part
could determine the outcome of his race
back to the live shot of inside Madison
Square Garden you can see here where
they're reconstructing the set they're
making it that's circling around the
reason I'm asking is because on the far
left there is where the large you can't
see it but it's in that blue wall on the
far left that's where the huge
teleprompter is for people who were
speaking from the podium they're making
this in the round president Bush was
going to be speaking in the round I'm
asking how much of the speech is he
going to be writing himself will he have
it memorized will it be like on a
campaign appearance or will this be you
know use the teleprompter type speech
he'll have it largely memorized and
we'll use it it will be he will stay
with it he'll stay with the speech and
Karen use and Mike Gerson his brilliant
speechwriter are key figures in writing
this this is something they've been
working on for intently for a month
and really even longer than that the
themes the the phrasing is still being
I'm told even yesterday kind of tweaked
a bit but this is something he knows
what he's going to say and that's what
he's is going to use you know when
you're on the campaign trail with the
candidates they get into their groove
and there will be pieces of this speech
that will be sort of riffs from the
campaign that they've memorized simply
by repetition but by and large elements
of this speech will be new and he will
have a very very familiar sort of an
imprinted on his brain when he goes out
in the circle so the president as Oprah
tonight will he have a lot of input into
what what the words are oh yeah yeah I
can I remember and I say this again this
was in August 1999 beef when he very
early 1999 when he was just beginning
the process of preparing to run for
president in back in Texas and he went
to the gravesite of military veterans
for a Veterans Day Memorial and I would
evaluate it was a memorial for it for it
to honor some veterans but it wasn't
Veterans Day and he gave this speech
with Mike which Mike Gerson who was new
on the staff had written it was gorgeous
it was beautiful the phrasing was
lyrical and I sat there and next to Carl
next to Karen used and I said where is
that coming from it did not sound like
George Bush and what happened over the
weeks that followed was you had this
sort of the sort of reproach mom where
you had on the one hand the speech
writers ability to write didn't match
the speaker's really approach at
speaking straightforward more like
regular guys from Texas and so you
betcha he has a lot to say not only
about the themes but about the phrasing
I've seen him in past speeches look at a
phrase and mark it out and say that's
not the way I would say this so in the
end he's he's in charge Sickler Ville
New Jersey you're the last call for
Wayne Slater yes good morning
I commend her a guest for his
objectivity I have two quick points one
in in regard to Zell Miller I think that
the media is complicit in perpetuating a
historic American hypocrisy Zell Miller
was always the Dixiecrat and he remains
the Dixiecrat he brings to mind senator
Bilbo cotton ed Smith and all those
demagogues of the period my second point
is that the media has avoided
publicizing the testimony an interview
of Ben Barnes I challenge this man to
put that video on television so America
can see it well briefly the first point
certainly Zell Miller is a Dixiecrat and
and that's true with respect to Ben
Barnes Ben Barnes important person back
in the late 60s was the House Speaker in
Texas lieutenant governor in Texas and
basically he was the guy you went to if
you were someone who wanted to get your
son into the national guard recently in
Texas he spoke before a group of
Democrats and said in effect I got
George Bush into the guard I assisted
the process at the request of a family
friend that has been written we wrote it
in 2000 the friend was named Sid Adger
this is not a secret that this had been
said before but what's new is that
Barnes seems to
be taking a more direct and personal
responsibility for as a person in power
making sure that the the George Herbert
Walker Bush is son got into the National
Guard and say now that he kind of that
he regrets it the Republicans say that
the Ben Barnes is a republic rat
fundraiser and they would expect no less
others point out that Barnes has
supported some Republicans back in Texas
including the current Comptroller of
Texas who is the mother of Scott
McClellan the the spokesman for the
President of the United States is a good
debate it's out there I think people can
look at it and decide
Wayne Slater is co-author of Bush's
brain he's also the Austin bureau chief
for the Dallas Morning News thanks for
being with us good to see you and we've
got about in about ten minutes we'll be
joined by Frank Ricci Yahtzee he